this video is brought to you by war
thunder
[Music]
what's up wisecrack jared here i'm not
sure if you've noticed a trend lately
but a lot of very smart people are
acting
incredibly dumb elon musk made some very
bold and very wrong statements about
coronavirus
musical genius kanye west has announced
a run for president without even filing
the right paperwork and i can't seem to
go a day without finding out some
award-winning scientists hawking weird
pseudoscience
professor montagne is first of all a
medical doctor
a pragmatist he's convinced that water
memory opens a new area of research for
medicine
this is not the hate on musk or kanye
one is in my humble opinion a musical
genius and the other changed the
landscape of cars with tesla but what if
some of the weirder antics of people
like musk
aren't just regular human error but
speak to a bigger problem about how we
understand intelligence
in other words why do geniuses act so
dumb
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
myth of genius
and no spoilers ahead but before we
continue i want to give a shout out to
this week's sponsor
war thunder from the makers of crossout
and star conflict comes war thunder
a free large-scale combat mmo that's
available on pc
ps4 and xbox one in the game you can
fight in history's most iconic battles
by air land or
sea take your t-80 on a world tour and
shoot down some helicopters
or send a massive cruiser to the bottom
of the sea with war thunder's high-end
graphics it's like being
in the middle of history there are more
than 1500 combat vehicles and over 350
unique airplanes to choose from
the flight sim is one of my favorite
parts since they spare no detail in what
it's like to fly a plane
you can customize your vehicles with
upgrades mods and even custom skins
then once you're ready you can choose a
battle from world war ii the cold war or
a modern conflict anywhere on the globe
war thunder is always updating the game
so there's always something new to
explore
you can download the game today for free
by using the link in the description
when you download the game using our
link you'll get some awesome bonuses
that guarantee
some wins at the get-go so download the
game today
and now back to the show to really
understand the strange paradox of genius
i want to tell you the story of linus
pauling
born at the beginning of the 20th
century linus pauling was a titan of
science
in his 30s he proposed a third way atoms
could bind together called
orbital hybridization he then went on to
identify several key features of dna
structure created a formula to measure
electronegativity
and discovered the underlying mechanism
behind sickle cell anemia
for all his work pauling has the
distinction of being only one of four
people in history to win
two nobel prizes though one was a peace
prize so if anyone gets the genius title
it's pauling right well maybe not
pauling made another contribution to
science orthomolecular medicine
coined by pauling in the late 60s the
term refers to the practice of treating
everything from the common cold to
psychosis
to cancer to even aids with vitamins
taken at extremely high megadoses now i
don't think it takes a genius to know
that vitamins won't cure cancer but at
the time
this idea gained some major traction
after all one of the smartest scientists
alive was not only advocating for it but
even publishing multiple books about it
but the wider scientific and medical
community wasn't buying it
the american psychiatric association for
example wrote a blistering report in
1973
questioning why pauling's vitamin of
choice niacin
seemed to never provide the results he
claimed when experiments were performed
by independent investigators
the apa's major concern was that his
claims were at best unprovable and at
worst
dangerous despite them calling the
practice and its claims deplorable and
the american academy of pediatrics
calling it a
cult linus pauling only doubled down
until he died in 1994.
after his death a 1996 study on the
effects of vitamin a and beta-carotene
on heavy smokers had to be cut short
after lung cancer rates soared 28 and
the mortality rate rose a horrifying 17
among the participants all of which
raises the very simple question
how did one of the world's smartest men
end up being so
dumb and why do we continue to worship
him in spite of this
even catapulting his pseudoscience to
the new york times bestseller list
as it turns out the idea of genius is a
relatively modern concept the latin word
genius originally referred to an
individual spirit that inhabits and
protects a person from their birth
thereby determining their character
which isn't that surprising when you
consider the latin root of genius is
gigner
or to birth or beget so when you grew up
to be a tough-as-nails general or a
talented bard ancient romans would chalk
up your talents to your individual
genius and there's a certain appeal to
this
this roman sense of the word can explain
why someone excels in a certain area
without committing us to believe they're
great at everything using this sense of
the word we can immediately see the
problem with linus pauling
the guy was a brilliant chemist and a
biologist looking at the proteins of
misshapen blood cells but not exactly a
shoo-in for cancer doctor of the year
it wasn't until the 1600s that our
modern notion of genius started to
emerge
the word began to refer to a specific
individual with a natural intelligence
or talent and exalted natural mental
ability
and this is where the problem starts
where genius begins to gain the revered
catch-all status it has today
the words evolving definition
corresponds with the larger cultural
shift of the european enlightenment
this was a time of unparalleled
intellectual growth in western europe
manifesting everything from the birth of
modern science to the creation of
calculus
astronomy and economics central to all
this intellectual progress though was
the idea that man could
through his intellect unlock the keys to
the universe and change our world for
the better
this is around when we start to see
glimmers of our modern day genius
warship
18th century french philosopher anne
robert jacques turgot for example
asserted that progress only occurs when
an
individual genius makes advances in
their field according to turgot
states have the responsibility to foster
these geniuses and allow them to
flourish
in his eyes there probably wouldn't be
anything wrong with government
subsidizing tesla or solarcity through
lucrative tax credits or giving kanye's
fashion brand yeezy a small business
loan in the wake of covet 19.
it's all in the service of further
developing their genius
19th century scottish philosopher and
mathematician thomas carlisle takes this
idea of worshiping geniuses one step
further
in his book on heroes hero worship and
the heroic in history
carlisle famously stated that the
history of the world is but the
biography of great men
in carlisle's view a select few geniuses
were responsible for all the major
developments throughout history
while us lay people were just along for
the ride after all history won't
remember the original founders of tesla
engineers martin eberhard and mark
tarpening much less credit that
countless other designers or technicians
who have worked towards the company's
success but we won't forget elon musk
american philosopher sydney hook perhaps
best encapsulates this perspective
arguing that genius is not the result of
compounding talent how many battalions
are the equivalent of a napoleon
how many minor poets will give us the
shakespeare how many run-of-the-mill
scientists will do the work of an
einstein
but even though they lauded geniuses
they still distinguish between different
kinds of geniuses
thomas carlisle for example divided his
great men into six categories he
wouldn't for example compare the genius
of a priest like martin luther to that
of a poet like john milton
similarly francis galton the father of
the sense extremely debunked theory of
eugenics broke down the star-studded
world of geniuses into categories
ranging from judges and statesmen
to scientists painters poets and even
oarsmen
now galton and carlisle aren't exactly
the standard for today's scientific
exploration of genius but if you want to
look at the world of smart people saying
dumb things
a pretty good red flag is people
venturing outside of their speciality
that isn't to say that multi-platinum
artist kanye west isn't allowed to have
political opinions or that scientists
haven't excelled in multiple fields but
in today's world of hyper-specialized
knowledge
nothing about understanding how jet
propulsion works makes one an expert on
epidemiology
nowhere is this more apparent than when
you venture into the world of
pseudoscience
there you'll see a crop of phds and md's
venturing outside of their speciality
claiming to be some revolutionary
thinker
despite their lack of training or
peer-reviewed publications on the topic
take for example someone like ivar yaver
who despite being awarded a nobel prize
for proving electron tunneling occurs in
superconductors
also happens to be among the biggest
climate change deniers in the scientific
community
on the one hand a genius on the other a
dum-dum there's also just people who go
off the rails
take luke montage who proved that a
retrovirus causes aids only to turn
around and publish
two papers claiming that dna can produce
electromagnetic signals when deluded
aka basically homeopathy montier's
claims were met with scorn from the
scientific community but this is only
half the story there's
another reason modern society valorizes
geniuses like albert einstein or elon
musk presuming them to somehow have
special brains capable of tackling any
problem regardless of the topic which
brings us to iq
cast your mind back to the french
countryside in the early 20th century
universal education has just become a
thing and as your classroom is flooded
with children from all sorts of
backgrounds
you need to identify which ones have
special education needs so they can get
extra attention
how do you do this well if your
psychologist alfred binet and his
assistant theodore simon you decide to
test
each child to determine what their
mental age is
a child who could answer all the
questions expected of a typical
eight-year-old would be said to have the
mental age of
eight but if the next eight-year-old
could answer the questions for a typical
nine-year-old they'd have a mental age
of nine
now it's important to note that bene
didn't think this number could fully
quantify a child's intellectual capacity
or potential
merely that it could predict how a child
would perform in school at that point in
time
just because a young linus pauling built
a chemistry lab from scratch and likely
had a higher mental age than his peers
wouldn't in benay's mind mean that the
other kids couldn't catch up
even though binet wasn't trying to
quantify genius two psychologists
independently took benay's model and
tried
to do just that the first was louis
turman if binet was against the idea of
ranking people by intelligence turman
was
all for it inspired by galton's theory
of hereditary genius
and benay's mental ages turman decided
he was going to scientifically
quantify intelligence to do so he
applied a simple formula
mental age divided by physical age times
100 equals intelligence quotient or iq
so if you can answer a question that a
10 year old can and you're only 5
ten divided by five is two times a
hundred is two hundred
you're a genius with this simple
calculus turman instituted the modern
regime of iq testing as we know it today
ranking and sorting everyone from school
students to army recruits but this
massive wave of testing brought to light
an interesting fact as english
psychologist charles spearman first
noted
scores across different portions of
different iq tests were positively
correlated in other words kids who were
good at pattern recognition for example
were also good at vocabulary
and memorization intelligence it would
seem wasn't tied to specific subjects or
areas
instead this statistical correlation
implied what spearman called a general
intelligence better known
as g we now had a modern conception of
genius
a genius was someone with a high iq
which made you smart about almost
everything in committing to this view we
as a society had completed a u-turn on
our pre-enlightenment views
genius was no longer something that
everyone possessed a characteristic or
quirk to explain their personality
instead it's the domain of the
hyper-intelligent and we should revere
them for it
so don't criticize elon musk for dipping
his toes into predictive modeling in
cobit 19
even if he's catastrophically wrong and
don't you dare think that hawking
vitamins as a cure for cancer is
essentially a multi-level marketing
scheme with less steps
we often give these people the benefit
of the doubt just because they're
seemingly much smarter than us or at
least that's what the cultural narrative
wants us to do it's the reason why
albert einstein with zero political
experience was offered the presidency of
israel in 1952
because he's just so smart but einstein
understanding that his genius was not
universal
declined it citing his complete and
utter lack of experience in the matter
and here's where we can understand how
turman and spearman got a lot about
intelligence wrong
despite its prominence in popular
culture the iq test
and the concept of monolithic g has been
under sustained attack from
psychologists for decades
the problem is that intelligence tests
whether they're dealing with logical or
spatial reasoning
are only measuring intelligence in a
certain sense it's hard to see how an iq
test will spot the person who's going to
make the next big contribution to music
or how a kid with impeccable spatial
reasoning will do in the floor is lava
according to psychologist robert
sternberg this is where most
intelligence tests fail they refuse to
look into the context of what they
measure
in sternberg's view we're suffering from
predictor criterion confusion that's a
fancy way of saying we're using iq tests
to reflect intelligence more than
real-world problem-solving
to sternberg intelligence has to take
into account the purposive
adaptation to shaping of and selection
of real-world environments relevant to
one's life
in other words intelligence doesn't
occur in a vacuum instead what's
considered intelligence changes
drastically between cultures
environments and situations
while being able to spend hundreds of
hours studying for the s.a.t might make
you smart by a college's standard for a
hunter-gatherer intelligence might be
linked to the ability to orient yourself
and your surroundings while tracking
prey
in both cases our intelligent human is
adapting to real-life scenarios to get
what they want even if these forms of
intelligence are very different
going back to kanye the only way to
measure his specific brilliance is to
hear his music
so here's the big question wisecrack if
our modern conception of genius rests on
iq tests that are kind of funk and a
concept of g that might not really mean
anything in a broader sense of
intelligence
is there really even such a thing as a
genius at all sure
elon musk has had moments of genius as
did linus pauling before him but what if
they're actually just smart people who
happen to stumble upon some breakthrough
ideas
as it turns out there's some evidence
this might be the case turman in his
quest for studying geniuses
actually embarked on one of the longest
running longitudinal studies in history
partnering with the california public
school system he used iq tests to
identify the most gifted children and
then followed up with them for the next
35 years while turman hoped to find the
great men that carlisle theorized moved
history
instead most of his approximately
fifteen hundred geniuses
went on to live normal lives in a
devastating analysis sociologist peter
himsoricon demonstrated that turman's
geniuses did just as well in life as a
random sampling of kids from a similar
socioeconomic status
in other words genius level iq didn't
produce any linus pauling's or elon
musks
in fact as journalist malcolm gladwell
points out herman actually tested and
ultimately rejected two individuals who
went on to win nobel prizes
maybe genius isn't a number then but
rather the happy accident of a
hard-working
lucky and ultimately normal person and
maybe they get a boost from specific
kinds of reasoning skills
terence tau the winner of the fields
medal in 2006
kind of like the nobel prize for math
except much more exclusive
takes just this view he argues the
popular image of the lone
and possibly slightly mad genius who
ignores the literature and other
conventional wisdom and manages by some
inexplicable inspiration to come up with
a breathtakingly original solution to a
problem that confounded all the experts
is a charming and romantic image but
also a wildly inaccurate one
to tau genius isn't the result of the
great men that carlisle proposed
instead the genius stands atop the
shoulders of those that came before
whose small incremental advances led to
the geniuses breakthrough it's not
brilliant
it's simply progress obtained naturally
and cumulatively as a consequence of
hard work
directed by intuition literature and a
bit of luck but what do you think
wisecrack did the simulation just short
us the intelligence needed to fully
appreciate the legend that is elon musk
let us know in the comments how smart or
dumb you think we are for writing this
thanks to all our awesome patrons for
supporting the channel and our podcast
slam that subscribe button to prove how
smart you are
or don't and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Applause]
[Music]